There is one simple fact that has yet to penetrate
very deeply into the policy world.
Our economic future, like that of other nations
of the world, depends directly on the quality
of our workers.
More specifically, in this increasingly technological
age, the cognitive skills of future workers
will determine much of our economic wellbeing.
Given that simple fact, the backlash against
testing in schools and against accountability
for results is a bit scary.
From international testing in math, we find
that U.S. students rank 39th in the world,
putting us below the average for developed countries
and having us competing with Croatia and Greece.
You might ask, isn’t our economy still the
envy of the world?
And the answer is “yes for now”, but not necessarily
in the future.
We have been able to benefit from good economic
institutions with limited governmental intrusion,
with more schooling than elsewhere, and with
high-skilled immigrants.
But the future strength of each is in doubt,
and we will have to rely on the skills of
our population for ongoing success.
Do you think that it is possible for our schools to compete with the best in the world?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.